new motivation was the top 10 with
belief nation hey it's Evan Carmichael
and this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know you've got something greater
inside you as well you've got Michael
Jordan level talent at something so get
ready to outwork everyone get obsessed
and take action with EDM I let and my
take on his top ten rules a success vol
10 joy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one outwork everyone I'm addicted to one
more and so I want your much we're going
forward to be one more what does that
look like if we're working out that
means when we're in the gym and we say
I'm gonna do five sets of ten I'm crazy
like I'm a psycho cuz I want to win I
want to be somebody I want to separate I
want to compete and the way I do that
isn't with my giftedness because I
wasn't born with a bunch of gifts and I
think gifts are crap I think for the
most part gifted people struggle in life
because things come easy them I like the
things haven't come easy for me in my
life I like to have natural talents in
every area and maybe you like that about
you too maybe you've looked at yourself
all your life and thought man I don't
have that natural beauty or that natural
talent or this gift for creativity or
intellect or humor I don't have any of
those things but what I got is I will
outwork you and so at the gym one of the
things I focus on they say it's five
sets of 10 when I'm at ten I go one more
BAM 11 if I'm running on the treadmill
and it's a 45-minute run I never finish
it 45 I always go one more minute 46 if
I'm at the office and I'm supposed to
make 25 phone calls that day when I'm at
the end of the day I always do one more
if I've got meetings I always do one
more
my mantra for three decades in business
has been one more rule number two get
obsessed let's talk first of all about
getting laser focus and I mean this is
your friend
I mean it's talking to myself too I
always cover things that make me matter
things that I struggle with but I gotta
tell you
I think there's a different level for
you I mean I think there's a different
level for you to get obsessed crazy
laser focus I say all the time
our obsessions become our possessions
but we won't possess them if we're not
truly obsessed I bet there's been a
person in your life you've been obsessed
with if you're over 20 years old listen
to this
more than likely you've had somebody you
were pretty obsessed with haven't you
that you wanted in your life you wanted
to date you wanted as a girlfriend or a
boyfriend or a significant other how
many times a day do you think about them
how many times a day did they distract
you from what you were doing with just
the thought of them in other words this
is what I want you understand when your
laser obsessed focused your obsession
distracts you from what you're currently
doing not the other way around you're
not really obsessed with it if you're
easily distracted from it this is so
important you right now can test whether
it's your obsession with whether it
distracts you constantly the first thing
you think of when you wake up last thing
before you go to bed when you have a big
laugh it comes up when you cry it comes
up when you're watching TV it comes up
when you're doing your regular job but
it's your side hustle it comes up you
can't stop thinking about it it
distracts you from the rest of your life
that's what an obsession does when it's
not really your obsession the rest of
your life distracts you from it and so
that it in your life is so important but
there's all these things that distract
us today I'm gonna give you a
recommendation turn your damn TV off
turn the radio off most of the time turn
your phone off a lot too rule number
three take action you got to rise up
you're gonna make your dreams a reality
and live a damn masterpiece you know
this now here's the thing couple things
you got to make a decision listen to me
you got to make a decision what's the
decision what's the thing you came here
for now we're at the moment the clock is
ticking people say all the time hey life
is short let me tell you something life
can be long you bury your dreams you
quit this life gets long C times
relative to minutes of you being with
your sweetie doing whatever you'd like
to do with them that can go by quick
right what about the last two minutes on
a treadmill does that not seem like it
goes by for like four hours
right so if you're enjoying it it's
short if it's painful it's long life can
be long you want a life that feels like
it's flying by
you want a life like I have right now
where I go can I just press pause okay I
just press pause it's so good it's so
great it's so rewarding it's so awesome
but I don't want really want to press
pause because I know it can get better
so what's the decision what have you
been sitting on what is it is it people
are texting me hey and I submitted my
resignation last night I'm coming
full-time I walked away from a
six-figure job is that the decision is
that the decision to finally get serious
is the decision to get license is the
decision to stop worrying about what
people think is the decision to become a
great closer if the decision is
something in a relationship you have you
need to get out or in two it's only a
thought if you don't take an action the
difference between a thought and a
decision is an action so we know and you
know you just decided and you know what
it is you know what it is you will have
really decided if within this next hour
you took some step towards it something
a note you write a text you send a
decision you've made something you do
that you follow up with the action to
make it real rule them before stop the
comparison game it's not the success of
people you know that's making you
unhappy it's you're comparing your
situation to the success they're having
that creates unhappiness in your life so
for those of you that are struggling and
saying you know one of the things I
suffer from is I'm just not very happy
very often I can tell you that that
presence of unhappiness
you will always link to a comparison of
some sort either in your own life or in
other people's lives and just being
aware of that fact and stopping the
comparison embracing this moment
embracing this time knowing that you
can't go back to that previous time
knowing that you can't be in somebody
else's life you're not gonna have that
other body right now and so if you're
looking to be happier I can promise you
the number one key that I would give you
is to stop the comparison game you say
well that's not completely true I mean
what if someone passes away that makes
me unhappy
there's no comparison there let's take
the most extreme example or when
someone's sick in my family you know
there's someone in my family's
a really bad illness that makes me
unhappy that's not a comparison in fact
it is the fact of the matter is that
when someone gets sick and your family
or passes away what you do in your mind
is you compare it to when they were
healthy so that comparison of I wish
they were healthier again that is a
comparison between the previous
situation and the current condition if
someone passes away it's comparing the
time that you had them that's why people
say if I could just have one more moment
with them if I could just have another
conversation it's comparing it to when
you had the moment it's comparing it to
when you had the conversation and so
those are extreme examples but if we
reduce it all the way down to anything
right now in your life that you say it
brings me unhappiness there's no joy
there there's a comparison happening
that's not serving you all so if you
want to have more confidence check on my
254 series it's free the link to join is
in the description below the minute you
begin to get external in your life
worrying about what other people think
about you right you vote you've lost all
control you and it never fills you up
rule number five alter your daily
choices the power of choice is critical
in our lives I want you to think about
something right now what are five of the
most important choices you've made in
your life just think about that for a
second begin to list them off in your
head five of the most important choices
you've made in your life maybe it was a
decision to get involved in a particular
business or to leave a particular
business maybe it was a decision to get
involved with a particular person or to
become uninvolved with a particular
person maybe it was a friend but you
chose to walk across the room and meet
and it changed your life maybe was a
friend that you had to walk away from in
order to improve your life what are the
five most important choices of your life
just think about them for a second and
if you altered those five choices good
bad or indifferent how different would
your life be today because I'm a
believer that there's everyday choices
we make that when you stack them up they
make a massive difference in our life
but I'm also believer that there are
between five and ten a handful of
moments in everybody's life that if we
make the proper choices in those moments
the complete trajectory of our life
changes and I think as you just asked
yourself that question you may say there
haven't been five there's been two what
were they and how they alter the
direction of your life rule number six
look back 60 to 90 days when I'm having
a difficult time in my life in one area
another all I have to really do is look
back 60 to 90 days and it's the
behaviors I had 60 to 90 days ago that
are causing the results I get negatively
right now and so like for example when
I'm not really you know progressing in
my career or in my financial situation
if I look back 60 to 90 days prior I
stopped reading the books listening to
the audios doing the things that grow my
identity and I pay the price 60 to 90
days later in my body my body isn't
looking like I want it to if I look back
60 to 90 120 days that's what my diet
got weaker that's when my workouts
weren't quite as intense as they were
previously and I pay the price three to
four months later this is true in every
area of our life our lives are almost
like reading a newspaper today but we're
reading the headlines for 90 days ago
and so that's what confuses people they
see the external results of their life
but what if you did if you read the
newspaper from ninety two hundred and
twenty days ago that's where the news
was made not today and so in every area
of your life you got to go in right now
you got to fuel the fire if you've got
your business going your finances going
your relationship going your faith going
where you want it to you have to
continue to do the activities that got
you here in the first place because 90
days from now you're gonna read today's
news that's how it works
rule number seven choose the life you
want it's a hard thing to accept but in
our lives we are getting out of our life
right now exactly what we believe we're
worthy of exactly what we think we
deserve our life is a direct reflection
of our identity which is the thoughts
concepts beliefs values and worth we
hold true to be about ourselves and so
as hard as it is to accept we're getting
out of life right now what we believe
we're worth and we believe we're worth
it because of these patterns and our
identity and our lack of choosing to
have what we want not just the material
things not just the body fat not just
the body weight not just
the amount of money not just having the
relationship but choosing the emotion we
want the level above all this stuff I
discuss and the level way down here were
the people discover the basic stuff then
there's what I've been covering the
highest level is to choose the emotions
we want to experience and to begin to
run patterns that serve us and eliminate
the ones who move us further from them
rule number eight write your own story I
want you to think about something real
quick
see there's a book being written about
your life isn't there someone somewheres
take an inventory of your life don't
compare your chapter one - someone's
chapter ten you write your own book and
at any moment in your life you can
decide that you want to make this the
new chapter your turqu literally in your
life you can turn the page and those
previous chapters are your old book
it's like Old Testament New Testament
old story new story they're connected
they're related but you can flip the
page and you can have a whole new story
if you decided right now I am literally
turning my breakthrough is I turn the
page and in this second I start to write
the best chapters of my life you could
decide to do that rule number nine don't
let your ego hold you back if you meet
people that you think are ego maniacs
that are constantly bragging about
themselves these are the most insecure
people that you know they're the most
fearful people that you know they're the
most scared and they're usually the
least happy and so but I'm gonna say
something to you I want you to consider
as I go through ego today I know you
think well I'm so down on myself how can
I have an ego it's actually the people
that are down on themselves that
actually have their ego materialize and
show up more often than they think and
it's their Eagle that may actually be
holding them back you think wow how
could someone with low self-esteem have
a big ego of trust me they do and so
egos are not part of people with high
self esteem the people in my life that
are the most self-confident typically
don't have big egos but if you have to
wait around for other people to tell you
how your egos out of control it's too
late usually so we've got to be able to
see our ego when it rears its head be
aware of it and it loses its power over
us we can go back to being our real
selves you can't love yourself if you're
not being yourself you can't love
yourself if you're not being yourself
when ego shows up we're not
our selves we're not connected to God in
other words if you can let go of your
ego you can let God in when you can let
go of your ego you can let your real
confidence in when you let go of your
ego you can go really become who you
were born to be and so oftentimes this
is so important you get you may be
losing right now because of your ego
because of your ego because you're not
feeling good about yourself I'm your
number 10 the last one you for a very
special bonus clip is change your
identity I think most people back as
their identity and so I'm pretty good at
getting people to change their identity
in other words your identity as the Fox
concept believes values that you hold to
be true about yourself then your life is
gonna be very consistent about your
identity is for the most part in the
room right next to Matt I could steer
that you can't there's a thermostat
sitting on the lawn there that
thermostat regulates the temperature of
the room it's not at 75 degrees so right
now I open up the doors it's a cold
rainy day here I live right on the ocean
a bunch of cold air is blowing in here
right now but the rooms not gonna cool
down but the external conditions the
rooms gonna heat back up 75 degrees
because that thermostat will he beat the
room up to get it to the temperature
it's set up its identity if I open that
door and hot air blew in here which
probably is now that I'm starting to
clock conditioner will turn on and cool
that room back to 75 degrees it
regulates the temperature your identity
regulates the temperature of your life
no matter what happens the external
conditions can get better and better and
better
you make it more money or you're more
thin or you have a better relationship
but if you don't change your identity
that's if you're a 75 degree and you're
getting 85 90 95 degrees of results
you'll find a way over pretty short
period of time to turn the air
conditioner back down and get those
areas right back to where your identity
is and that's why you'll see people
getting in and then come back lose
weight and gain it get a great
relationship and lose it make a bunch of
money and get back now I have a special
bonus cup from Ed on how to be patient
that I think you're gonna enjoy but
before that is time for the three-point
landing questions let's go from just
watching the video to taking
action here we go question number one
what's the identity change that you need
to make number two what's one daily
choice that you can alter starting today
and number three who do you need to stop
comparing yourself to and if you like
this video and you're going to take
action after watching it give me a hash
tag believe down the comments as well
see today one of the reasons so many
people are confused about their lack of
success is because we live in a very
immediate gratification type society
meaning people expect results to happen
instantaneously because we can get
access to information instantaneously
media we can get music we can get a
movie we can get a Google search we can
get a book we can get anything we want
instantaneously but what you can't get
instantaneously is success in life and
we've been raised in a generation now
many of us even older guys like me we're
programmed to get things right now and
this hurts us in life because we don't
realize the echoes of life
if you want more edmy let check at the
top 50 rules video I made on him the
link is right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there to the person you are
destined to be ever in your life the
thing that's gonna kill your dream is
your addiction to other people's
approval I'm constantly in a crisis